Jessica Alba is far from finished as an
actress but we can't help noticing that
we just aren't seeing as much of her as
we used to while she seems to appear in
a couple of movies each year her career
has descended from the high-profile
heights of her superhero and Dark Angel
days for a little while on the wake of
the first couple fantastic four movies
it seemed like she might have been done
with showbiz for good what was so bad
behind the scenes that Alva almost
disappeared the script sucked Alva has
suffered through more than her fair
share of serious critical busts but the
Fantastic Four movie seemed to be the
last straw venting about all the bad
scripts she'd accepted over the years
Alva told Elle good actors never use the
script unless it's amazing writing all
the good actors I've worked with they
all say whatever they want to say a
reaction to those comments was Swift
screenwriter John August took her to
task for her perceived rudeness writing
following your logic you've never been
in a movie with both good actors and
amazing writing that may be true but it
might hurt the feelings of David Wayne
Robert Rodriguez and Frank Miller still
it's telling that Auguste failed to
mention Tim story director of the
Fantastic Four either maybe even he
recognized that maybe album might have
been justified in hating that one and
speaking of Tim story they made her feel
worthless there can't be anything more
demoralizing for an actor than being
asked not to do their job but that's
exactly the sort of treatment Alba says
she received during the filming of the
wildly Pam Fantastic Four sequel during
one scene and rise of the Silver Surfer
Alva was supposed to be emotional
director Tim story reportedly berated
her saying it looks too real it looks
too painful
according to Alva he was like don't do
that thing with your face just make it
flat we can CG the tears in and so I
just said I don't care about this
business anymore the movies were ripped
apart by critics an overinflated B movie
with no grace no subtext no wit and
featuring beefcake / cheesecake actors
terribly miscast the movie should almost
be ashamed to show itself there's no two
ways about it
far from fantastic these movies were
horribly received especially compared to
John ricchan temporaries like spider-man
- Batman Begins an x-men the reviews
were particularly unkind to the actors
their performances were called thin
their characters two-bit and critics
generally wrote off their hard work as a
waste of time at a hurricane of hate
would be enough
to make anybody doubt their career
choices for her part Alba has shown a
lot of self-awareness when it comes to
the quality of some of her pictures
telling el I know I haven't been
swimming at the deep end with some of
the movies I've done I wasn't trying to
I knew what they were I've been so
afraid of criticism ever since I was
young
every time I get a critique or some
redirection I'd always just take it very
personally is that any surprise she'd
want to walk away thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw
you